we should welcome back to zagrev you
were here in 2021 what kind of memories
do you have from that event
uh 2021 uh the Zagreb tournament
first of all it was a very long event
because I had to come three weeks early
due to the pandemic and so I I remember
that tournament is just being in these
surroundings forever and in a pleasant
way I mean you're in a nice city right
in the center for a month and um
and I had lots of uh local friends here
coming and trying to give me company and
so on so it felt not only like a very
big tournament but also very social one
and um
it was very important because it was a
very good result for me and it gave me a
lot of confidence that yeah
um
yes and I hadn't played much and so I
when I came here and I finished second
that year uh you know that was a very
positive thing to take away and Gary was
also playing in that event so uh big
event this year again it will be very
very tough that's the thing if you have
just all the top players in the
grandchester so uh tough event and uh
but again I've learned meeting up all my
friends and all that and trying to get
into positive spirit for the event yeah
absolutely the last time we saw in
granchester was actually in Poland last
year and you were leading I remembered
the whole event and don't let the ant
slow down a little bit and still became
third like what are your you know goals
in this one are you going to push also
to try to get into the first places
my attitude always is you have to play
Move the pieces and the position has to
take care of itself you don't really aim
for this or that but of course I'll try
to do my best and play good moves
um
yeah like I said your score if as long
as keeps moving along uh hopefully it's
uh it keeps you in the front
now that you play rapid and Blitz I mean
do you have some special kind of tricks
and methods methods how to stay focused
I mean during those games
generally when we have this because we
start with the rapid you have to first
get in with three games every day uh
with the draw after the drawing of lots
today we will know the uh who we play
um
for me it's a it's a step up because in
the in Dubai I was playing one game a
day yes and so here suddenly we go to
three and uh but it's a format I'm used
to I played in Warsaw I played it in
sagreb a couple of years back when I was
a full tour participant I was playing
um two or three a year so
um
I'm used to this format generally you
you try to get into the tournament fully
uh big concentration and all that by the
end of the rapid
and then the blitz just goes past you
you have no idea what happens and you
just you just see where you ended up
with just
also um I mean speaking about many
events you mentioned the other events of
granchester what is was the most
memorable event for you
um for all during all these years
I like many of them
um
I generally you can imagine I remember
the good results better than the bad
ones
and so there are some events that leave
a scar on you but mostly the
grandchester events have just superbly
organized and I really enjoy playing in
them and like I said from two years ago
I have very good memories of Zagreb and
hopefully I can carry these wipes
forward to this year as well for sure I
mean also this event is special because
uh googesh is playing here and I had the
interview with him before and he said
that he's really looking forward also to
play against you and it's the first
tournament you're in the same one so
what do you think about him and his
participation he's a new for
grantchester
yes I'm very very proud of what he's
doing he's
I mean just couple of years back he was
starting his race and this year he's
been very consistent he had a good
result in
WR good recovery in bike very good
performance in Norway so you know
steadily making his way up and now it's
funny to talk about him some sort of
young Talent he's just number 15 in the
world exactly so you know there he is
um
and you know the nice thing is for the
last couple of years he has been one of
um
the students in my chess Academy
and uh it'll be funny to play him that's
true that's exactly what I'm looking for
and probably there will be I'm not quite
sure how to place it I just figure I'll
go there and look at the pieces and uh
you know not try to make a special game
out of it but just play good chess do
you remember yourself at the age of uh
good question like what were your
thoughts at that time
uh uh I remember I think I remember it
incredibly well uh generally my memory
now was
uh that everything was fun and
everything was nice and new and life
seemed exciting but uh
probably if I go back it was not quite
that straightforward uh typically your
Nostalgia takes over but I remember you
know these first chances at the big
tournaments and all how exciting they
were and yeah and the last question just
what do you think was the impact of
Grant's store itself for the history of
Chesterfield sport
in general these are clearly the premier
tournaments
uh in the world and you know they are
marquee events that everybody look
forward to and I think the the beauty of
the grandchester is because the points
accumulate at the end there's also this
curiosity not only who wins tournaments
but who is leading in the overall race
and who will win the tour at the end so
that's like an extra bonus like
um this year-end uh titles that they
have in many sports uh the grandchester
has great classical events great rapid
and Blitz events but also a tour winner
and that's a nice thing yeah exactly
thank you very much for your time and to
answering my questions and all the best
of luck for you in soccer thank you
[Music]